mohamed elias is struggling his bakery
delivery business has taken multiple
hits during sri lanka's economic crisis
he battles to find fuel and carries a
small amount around with him for
emergencies like this when his vehicle
stops mid route
skyrocketing prices have made his bread
and buns more expensive causing sales to
plunge
to carry on our business we must queue
for around four days sometimes petrol
supplies come sometimes they don't there
are lots of problems after all the
queuing we have to buy supplies the cost
of everything has increased
despite his own problems elias drove a
neighbor to this police station where
gas was being distributed
[Music]
after months of shortages tensions ran
high when hundreds of people jostled for
cylinders
we came here at three in the morning
because we heard gas was coming but it
didn't there are about a hundred of us
stranded we called the police who told
us the lorry was expected at the station
i don't have words to say how difficult
without fuel and
gas electricity and we don't have fiber
firewood
sri lanka is bankrupt authorities expect
inflation to reach 70 percent in the
coming months some economists say it's
already above 130 percent
a gold smith is also feeling the heat
we can't work without gas which we use
to make jewelry so we have to buy on the
black market at higher prices wedding
orders for jewelry have almost stopped
so we work one day on one day off
months of political upheaval and demands
for president gotabe rajapaksa to resign
have led to protesters overrunning his
official residence
rajapaksa has agreed to step down and
negotiations are underway to bring in an
all-party government whether it's buying
jewelry for the traditional wedding or
the weekly grocery shop the current
economic crisis has affected sri lankans
from all income levels they say
restoring economic and political
stability to bring down the cost of
living is the priority miller fernandez
al jazeera colombo